[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
yeah yeah I'm just gonna talk before it
because I I didn't update the lower
thirds either there's one thing I had to
miss but that's okay it doesn't matter
today we're here to play the half-life
remake Black Mesa which explain how this
is how this is out outage because you
were talking about how there's like a
like a beta beta version this has been
in the works for like 17 years they
started it I don't want to say back in
like all the way back in 2003 and it I
think it officially came out in like
2012 as an early access game on Steam it
was wanted like their first I think it
was actually one of the first things for
like green light or if you remember that
I remember it being a pretty big thing
so it's been in there forever and
today's the day that they were
officially releasing 1.0 unfortunately
it doesn't seem like 1.0 is actually
officially released it it it's by all
intents and purposes available to play
like it's it's there yeah the thing is
you can actually play 1.0
you just need to go to their public beta
yes activate that if you right-click on
the game so that is what we're about to
do so what we've done we're waiting
because the internet on this computer is
just being a absolute it's all
downloaded it's just gotta apply I think
so there's some wacky stuff but it's
okay because we're here to hang out in
either case regardless it's how'd it get
to be Thursday already I have no clue
[Music]
there's something up with that
microphone because people can definitely
hear me but I don't know why they can't
hear you and I don't know what we should
probably look at it maybe like the the
chords and you hear me now or like a
there's a thing you should supposedly
know wait
yeah no you can hear me right well it's
not as loud or as clear as me though
yeah yeah I'm wondering we should
probably look at that at some point yeah
probably should anyway sorry somebody in
the chat asked re completely Black Mesa
what has changed in 1.0 so apparently
the there's a couple things they changed
I know they really did a lot of the
enemy AI mm-hmm is apparently one big
thing that they were changing a lot so
that should be new they I've also just
like added a bunch of different tweaks
the interesting thing is they've also
said that they're still planning on
updating it past one oh really
yeah like they're gonna continue to
update the game which is very exciting
well it's a perfect time for them to do
this too because we're right on the edge
of falling into a brand new half-life
game we actually messed with our VR
setup in the speed zone the other day
playing a bit of bone works and stuff
and I'm very ready for Alex it's going
to be undoubtedly a great time but I
have no idea how I'm going to fit that
in between my multiple runs of doom in
collecting all the different bugs and
animals and animal crossing there's so
many games about to happen I'm scared
help me okay I'm seeing a progress bar
it looks like it's pretty far up there
even though it says 63% it's a pretty
full bar oops
never
it's moving it's moving quick yeah uh
anyway we can ask people how they're
doing how's your Thursday
hope you guys ready for tomorrow cuz
we're not playing a grand blue like I
said we were before surprise you may see
the the scheduled stream we're actually
playing halo Master Chief collection the
original Halo game finally came out on
Steam so if you have that it's ten bucks
if you don't have it by buying it by
itself you can join up with us tomorrow
for some good old hate like classic Halo
who knows what we'll do some capture the
flag in Blood Gulch maybe you could be
part of it but that'll all happen
tomorrow at the new stream time which
I'm still adjusting to 2 p.m. Pacific
look at those screenshots show people
probably don't want to look at us oh you
know what else is wacky we didn't we
didn't go to the game just gonna go to
the game right now and then if you hit
you right-click on a game for me right
click and then yeah yeah yeah you can
heck yeah let's get this all set up yeah
I'm gonna play this game you play that
game why are you talking not playing
it's because we're waiting for the game
to launch because our internet is dying
I guess I don't know you know how it
goes you know what it is what it do
but yeah we so somebody was asking about
changes in 1.0 and the big thing is that
they have completely over all the AI
soldiers like AI which is really
exciting but they kind of mentioned
right here they've also updated some of
the graphics in the older sections I
mean like the older parts of the game
have been out for a while like we said
yeah yeah in 2000 my mic is low again
it's that one's always low it's like
it's like it's broken I don't know I
know why speaking of broken what the
heck happened to this this input
right-click go to layout
I'm teaching Ben how to work it's been a
long time since I've touched excellent
hit reset on under cropping I'm an OBS
guy for sure
alright croppings here we said it boom
good work we're cooking again appreciate
it
yep there it is why is it going up it's
completely downloaded you know you gotta
wonder sometimes it's this is this is
the where's art yeah do this do this do
this what I was trying to say was
nothing basically if they've gone
through some of the older areas that
have been out for a while and they've
updated it's ready we're good to go
oh sure like I'm almost ready this is
all all coming together oh this is thank
you for hanging out with us on this
wonderful update stream good lord
alright cool adjusted I don't have to
save anything I can just exit out of
this it's good probably what you just
exit out of this and it's good oh hey
hey push live and just like that and
then you can X out of that they can see
they can see us now I'll move I'll move
the camera for you too late alright
that's fine
let's get this game I'm feeling that's
probably where the health is gonna be or
something I haven't played Black Mesa
since it initially went out but still
quite I literally have it the Mexican
possibly here oh wait a minute that's it
you mighty just fixed it cuz now I can
actually hear you in the preview head
but you can actually hear me now wow
that's all we need to do when you need
to just twist that knob a little bit I
thought that knob was up all the way the
knob was not not there we figured it we
fixed it nobody mess with that knob all
the streams going forward remember the
Black Mesa stream is the one where it
got fixed the left the left there was a
right side microphone for you guys it's
it's stage stage right my left it's
fixed I leaned my favorite stream we've
done so far yeah right this is this
great I'm feeling it holy [ __ ] the
sensitivity on this is bad Wow okay okay
that is where the health you know I'm
gonna move the camera already a wild
time the oh man that is a god it still
looks real good though it does give me a
second dress really don't need to see
John Luke's health right but you do yeah
you know what I'm just gonna do a live
let's just let's just go for it you know
in put it even more boom it was with you
guys are disappointing thank you dude I
ain't my business impress you know I'm
glad that you're all here for it okay
everything else is right sick and just
like that were we're a professional
stream again it's all yet look it's if
you don't look at any of the stuff
that's happened up until this point just
just now everyone start paying attention
now
oh I remember where I was I'm in a bad
spot I say just restart it yeah take it
for take it from the beginnin les this
is like the new content this is like
halfway through the game this is like my
playthrough I've been good at home
uh-huh you know let's keep it going was
the first time you fight the like
assassin soldiers oh yeah you get all
these these cool that cool dudes just
kind of hanging out it's been a long
time since I've also played half-life I
reinstalled them when Alex got oh yeah
oh you actually play them Black Mesa
gives you good luck there you go that's
a box quote for you but Black Mesa fixes
your what your mic mixing you want also
talk about how good that that HUD looks
with the the digital readout numbers
down there I really like that effect
okay
hello key I just tuned in right now in
the mic respects just like that heck
yeah
Brett Brannon came out of the best time
we're all together
I think I got them all heck yeah thank
God okay it's also really weird to see
uh the guns moving and not just aiming
straight for static all the time what's
this game about uh
do you want explain the plot of
half-life you play as scientist Gordon
Freeman who found a hazardous
environment suit and decided to wear it
there's an alien outbreak the military's
coming to shoot you up but you've got
your suit so you're good yeah there
needs to be more slack on that Mouse
weird this is just gonna be the stream
where we fix everything in the stream
room kids are ready do we have like a
USB extender cord like just to kind of
anyway there are four to Gaunt's they're
cool you meet up with there's one your
scientist friends Oh dr. kleiner he's
really cool he's got a he's kind of
nervous all the time
Eli Vance is cool his daughter Alex
Vance is also really cool she's gonna be
the star of the new half-life game
mm-hmm-hmm
playable in VR in a home near you guys
rank all the half-life games ooh
do we count remakes cuz half-life one's
got like what does this count as an
official remake now at this point it's
been sanctioned by valves so yes so this
is a so it's like what three three
different versions of half-life one - I
wouldn't count sorry this is just the
same game but with like but with ragdoll
physics yeah better water it's also a
box quote for you but play half-life
source it's got the water okay forgive
me I'm trying to figure out where to go
oh I wish it were doctor recliner doctor
recliner now I'm looking forward to
searching that later on in like a Google
Image thing and finding like like a
chair with the Photoshop picture
Kleiner's face on it thank you for the
explanation
it wasn't the best explanation but I
kinda just
you went for it when I think of
half-life those are the things that pop
into my head
just kind of random spitting spitting
out their favorite heavily frenemy oh
that's empty I instinctively wanted to
say headcrab only because they're like
the symbolic like when you think
half-life that's the thing but actually
I think I like the the things on the
ceiling what are they called
oh the things that grab you yeah because
they're they're just they're not even
like an actual enemy their molecular
mental hazard but just the idea of
something that sits up on the ceiling
waiting to grab stuff and pull it up
like that's there something I'm missing
I'm assuming us both go through these
doors oh you know I see it nevermind I
figured out sorry I know to do either we
or valve should make merch of doctor
recliner we know people we should talk
to them open up the valve store get
yourself a doctor recliner to help make
your half-life Alex VR experience that
much better take a load off and your
doctor articles thank that's it thank
you okay I really should get back to my
my half-life food this is uh totally
ominous dangerous whoa yeah it's
definitely dangerous
I remember this happening yes yes oh
yeah I remember this being a thing these
guys from from fear here to take you
away
got motion sickness watching this never
emerges oh no I
I don't know what to tell you that I
could turn the motion smoothing off if
you would defend my help
that's it give it a go it may be good
for helping out other thinking as well
also I'm gonna tea even more because
it's honestly just like really not
enough yeah if we can do anything to
make watching this much more you know
enjoyable
yeah it's turn a motion blur here that
helps you up it's the last thing we want
to do is make anyone sick
[Music]
it's weird cuz this like one of the few
moments in the game where that should
take control away from you for like a
second yeah oh is it a head bobbing
thing to shoot oh you get that it's head
bobbing I can also turn that off it's
really good that the Guffey's let me
know it's the head bobbing is the issue
our office just got approved for a
purchase of a full index kit next week
super stoked to play Alex with it oh
heck yeah right you lose all your guns I
at home have an oculus and that's
probably playing most of Alex on
I love the the oculus touch controls oh
right yeah trash compactor but we do we
do have an index here that I'd like to
try it on but we're playing bone works
the other day and it's real awkward to
remind yourself to let go of the
controllers say grab stuff right it is
it's gonna take getting used to but I'm
very excited to our half-life and fear
related takeaway scene you know that was
just my bad joke they as far as we know
are not related hey Emilio hey there
it's my good buddy Emilio you got the
clearance that's security Oh [ __ ] I
just had to wait for it to wait for it
to open up again I and I'm really hard
time not wanting to know when I got the
crowbar back encourage you to jump down
onto all those boxes down there oh never
mind probably jump down there anyway
right
nailed it it it shouldn't make me laugh
but almost every time gordon freeman
falls from a place that's too high up
and you get that's like quick bone crack
and you hear the the system voice doing
the administering whatever Oh Benjamin
says are you aware and other team is
doing a remake of opposing forces and
blue shift oh that's pretty cool I liked
a lot oh god what if we get a like a
Sven co-op - after all these get remade
be down for that joke wasn't bad oh
thanks I appreciate it like for health
so I would rather not they were really
into making sure that the like the goop
got all over your your hands and weapons
they are it's I respect it but it does
kind of feel a little annoying at times
here we go yeah anything up here oh yeah
the environments like the rocks that
kind of redid
in one point out you gotta have a good
rock texture so it looks a little bit
nicer which is good there is minor
fracture detected how many times does
gordon freeman fractured his like ankles
that's the question please look forward
to my GameSpot investigates feature
where I dive deep into the bone
structure of gordon freeman and how he's
as resilient as he is
imagine headcrabs in real life that's
the scary stuff I don't need that no
that's terrifying I'm not looking
forward to having to deal with them
Villar coming up we'll take we'll take
real life I'm curious if how many people
in the in the chat are planning on doing
a doing VR how many people why dude jump
look out there's so many of them how
many people have VR headsets are waiting
to kind of get in on it I know they were
sold out for a while I think they just
opened or just about to reel yeah um not
entirely up on it but uh you know what's
really shocking to me as valve is is out
here selling all these new index kits to
people and they're like buy these kits
get ready for half-life Alex but you
know what they haven't done that it
seems like an odd choice there's no like
VR game sale that they've done so like
have people play something to hold them
over right which seems like it I don't
know I don't know what the logistics are
cuz I'm not a businessman or anything
but a businessman I feel like that's the
thing that if I were valve I would try
to set up and make happen doing VR day
one heck yeah or to have an index 10 a
VR headset mmm I wish that the I wish
there was a way they kind of made it
available for other people to play too
but I also understand that they're
trying to like do a thing sort of save
definitely near future for me I'm
wondering how many people that will
actually like bring in to finally doing
VR I know actually at home Maya my
sister bought a VR headset not for
half-life but like just to have one she
got three requests so none really good
time with it yeah
if you are super expensive just for one
game totally understandable it took me
like I promised myself I wouldn't even
think about buying a VR headset until I
knew at least like 15 games that I would
want to play right and once I hit that I
started looking for for deals and there
was one it I just moved and I now only
have the space to even really use a VR
yeah so that's the other thing yeah for
me it was just like I need to be able to
even use it having the room is is a real
real big thing I can kind of cheat with
the oculus which is nice because it
doesn't need to do room scale properly I
miss something obviously the way to go
get the quest it's great headset doesn't
need a PC right it's true and the great
thing also about the quest is not only
does it not need a PC to run but it has
a cord that can hook up to a PC if you
want to use it for PC stuff so it's kind
of like the bucket like a Hannah Montana
best of both worlds kind of situation
you know back there so strange was that
a vertical that was a barnacle she's
just kind of like hang out and you go
god they just get you like that and you
get this really fun thing where you've
got to look up at the sky and just shoot
at it oh Jesus you got a gig he's sneaky
and they're also super unique and I
don't think any other game has right
okay and then you go up here because
using a very large empty classroom in
your office when we're closed for the
night so that's the that's the setup you
find like like a big open space that you
can just just tear it up yeah exactly I
guess I have to go down here I'm still
really stoked about how well the speed
zone works out for a VR area but we're
also talking about how when we get
half-life Alex and whoever's reviewing
it it's gonna need a babysitter to make
sure that they don't you really do
wander too far yeah okay yeah right
platforming oh great so you're living on
the edge right now with that 14 health
but you got 80 shields I guess can you
play Steam games on quests see that says
mentioning you can get the there's like
a cord that will let you plug it into
the PC that makes it function basically
as a regular oculus but outside of that
it's up you've got to like charge it up
and you can you connect it it runs off
of its own thing but with that cord you
should be able to I haven't done it
personally but it should work there we
go
I did it quitting time for you catch
y'all later have a wonderful streak oh
hey thanks for hanging out thanks for
you in the chat melee oh yeah if you
have a good rest of your evening and
yeah
so Brandon also coming in to say that
needs that link cable to play those
Steam games sweet did like the original
release have the extra animations for
when you spin it and stuff because I
don't even I don't remember it there I
don't think it did
a lot of thing I remember playing it
when it first came out and back in 2012
and then when I rehabbed in a couple
years ago I remember like all the
animations seemingly seemed to brand-new
to me I don't think I remember any of
these animations yes that might be
what's happening to me cuz I only played
like for the week that the early access
came out I was like I don't want to get
too too far another summer wait till it
actually is all eight years later I'll
most likely not be available in the
denied yeah I'm willing to bet that
that's uh that's a true fact no I got
that momentum going right into the GUP
thank God for quick save nope I had it
and then I I panicked it's all good
first-person games still not the best
for platforming but that's okay to make
make do yeah it's still kind of weird
got this dooms happening as I'd
accidentally watched like six trailers
for doom today very excited for that
game to happen me too
all right let's do it
so curious how are you planning to spend
your your big release day are you gonna
be my March 20th yeah you're gonna dive
in deep into and animal Crossing's is
your first your first one you're doing
it's my first animal crossing or you're
gonna even try to like shake doom off
all the way through first or depends I
[Music]
feel like the way animal cotton man even
maybe I'm wrong but the way Animal
Crossing works is it's you know you like
do what you can with in that day but
then end a certain point yeah it's like
well there's nothing else I can do today
so I will then wait till the next day
right thanks I assume like I'll do
everything I need to do for wow I did
not that was sick totally intentional
hey yeah I'm gonna do everything I think
I can do an animal crossing and then you
know see I'm worried about like game
whiplash if I do that no I love it
maybe I'll spend like the day playing
doom and then only switch over to Animal
Crossing like for evenings to wind down
or something cuz I'm coming up on the
end of Dragon Quest right now I need a
new game to play at nighttime
would not would like to not die please
thank you what yep they're gamers go get
that parkour we tried halos yep you're
actually talking about that we're gonna
play it tomorrow on the stream so if you
have it and you'd like to play with us
and everyone else back here same time
tomorrow and we'll be playing halo on PC
and you can play it with us yeah did
manage to play a little bit of it and it
runs well it's still weird to me that I
prefer the classic graphics settings
nigh and I don't like the there's
something with the way that we chose to
style it that I'm not it's too different
it's too it's too different but I don't
care for the way it looks
yeah I think halo twos anniversary they
nailed it more oh yeah we also had those
blare cutscenes to which really nice
cutscenes are beautiful going cut like
cutting back between the blur cutscenes
and they're like really janky Halo 2
cutscenes like really funny yeah okay
see this raft like remember like oh god
like where do I go just it's been a bit
what a game yeah we played doom eternal
first there's there's there's a it's
such a hard thing because I'm like I
want to rip and tear but I also want to
like seems like this was not the way I
should have caused fire here this is
dangerous but I also wanted like design
getting paid oh I can go underneath
there we go I think I'm making progress
half-life of Call of Duty physics get me
that health what is that that that
calming lo-fi beat that plays while you
like you
am I just hearing things that I've never
heard before like my solo fight
hip-hop's I guess so
I was extremely calming okay okay you
don't have a switch see there you go
you're you're locked in then Saleem
you've you've got it I think that just
got me this do crossing new help that's
what I need I need that crossover did
any bones break once just once
one minor fracture you did that sick
parkour thing though that should have
had a fractured bone but you you nailed
it I nailed it
okay back in we go
the devs finally released the the Zen
section they did they did they did it's
it's available to be played you can now
finish the game finish the fight do it
maybe oh maybe now that this is here all
instead of doing the original half-life
I'll play through this one so that's why
I decided because I was like I should we
do some half-life to get excited for
hello for Alex and I was like gosh I
play with the original one I was like
you know what I looked like Mason
instead I still feel bad because like
the original half-life came out in that
time when I was just like oh boy the
shooting game with the guns and I didn't
really like think about what I was
playing too much some I'm excited to get
that like run back on it as like an
adult who tries to pay attention to
things right so kind of the same thing
with Final Fantasy 7 I'm really excited
to like get the run back on that and not
be like a dumb kid that doesn't know
what they're doing but yes james's yours
of being a wild ride for me fan talofa I
don't really like listen the lo-fi stuff
all its I whenever I listen to something
at work recently it's been the guilty
gear soundtrack the doom soundtrack and
then when we get to like that weird like
2 p.m. 3 p.m. I'll switch over to like
we're relaxing Animal Crossing music
with rain sounds in the background and
that definitely doesn't help the fact
that I'm really tired but I love
listening to it and say it it was there
yeah oh
not dumb kids toys or eight I didn't get
to go to Toys R Us that much yeah I just
didn't like no it's it's weird like I
remember these things but I don't like
it's not committed to my memory I guess
and and all of its everything I'd like
to have that in a better a better
situation a better status I'll play
through it again
dr. incline that's pretty good job
that's that's the the treadmill exercise
equipment you can get so you hit your
doctor incline and then you you just
take a rest on doctor recline
oh there it is this flag Mason's got a
really good sound right I'll do some
science now if Gordon Freeman had like a
Bill Nye the Science Guy show this is
what the intro itself
[Music]
let's get some halo yeah it's gonna say
it's got a little bit of a halo feel
okay Wow
[Music]
I think so
dude you can't knock maybe that was cool
animal crossing asthma or that's I love
that in half life it's just it was just
he's a big sink and then it just goes
away
yeah and you're like oh that was awesome
and then back to no message I can't tell
if I'm going the wrong way or not we'll
find out I be the right way hello
we've made it to the next room okay this
is just oh you've got that quicksave
reflex on do you have you been dialing
your set
dude all the games like this yeah our
games are the old school design like
this you really have to I'm just like
yeah we're flexibly doing it I'll try mm
ugh is that the one that had kicks
slow-motion and like a um do you launch
her at one point because play the heck
out of that one when I was a kid
cuz I remember I would always play it
because it had the kick in the slow
motion but it also had a shovel now just
run through Raven home doing shovel only
runs I missed I miss doing PC mods me
too
where's Jess she's in Australia doing
that Australian thing would would they
be with idiot what time is it would they
be coming into the office or would they
still be kind of sleeping they'd be in
by now yeah it's their rounds it's not
here
hope I went the right way
I can no longer tell if I'm going the
right way or not you know it's I think I
went that way already I think I know
this guy your belt she does a major
fracture major fracture detected
it's my new funny Lowe's attic okay and
I think it may be major fracture do not
of the weak thing so this is right I
used to do that yeah oh yeah when you
were at a gym yeah when I was IGN I do
GTA mods everyone kept telling me I
sounded like badger from breaking bad so
that's where I was and watch that okay
so I'm all hop down here right
convention is working at Kingston
everyone get on this thing make Gordon
music that's my life it's just whenever
I can get mccord music get that BFG
division going okay so Aaron mod wasn't
the one I was thinking of
oh no I'm thinking of s mod that's what
it was to see if I did this right
yeah I'm flipping I'm down
Donna giving uh
especially I'm playing through half-life
2 again why not play a cool updated
version right now there we go sick jumps
thank you
yeah SiC jump Alvin
uh I'd like out like a mini like
counter-strike surfing flash back there
Oh fine didn't make it though like
incline on that wall looks like you
could definitely slide on it probably
good huh thinkin you got your health and
armor all the way back up again your
suit charged up going just somehow this
platform heavy this part of the game is
weird Toy Story 3 a situation that you
really need to get out of Oh God well I
watched that movie for the first time
like a couple months ago oh wow how's
that it's not a good movie to watch when
you're growing up nope I I had the
unique pleasure of watching it the
summer before I will have for college
you should say that's probably like the
the worst spot the most vulnerable
yikes it's a very good film though it
was oh my goodness I gotta be honest
I've only seen it once cuz I'm like I
don't think I can watch that movie again
yeah yeah that's versus like it's very
sturdy 1 & 2 I was like a billion times
as a kid I I can't believe like even
though I watched it like laughing like a
month ago I hadn't had it spoiled for me
so the only thing I'd sort of saw was
like ah the conveyor belts and stuff and
in the dump and I'm like that wasn't
even that sad I don't why everyone's
talking about it and then the actual sad
stuff happens and I wasn't ready if the
conveyor belt part is like you're like
oh god are they gonna do this yeah are
they actually gonna do this I mean my
friend in the theater like look at each
other okay and but then yeah but then
the actual sounds that happened we
watched her story for I haven't yet I
haven't either catch that on Disney Plus
like yeah
hmm okay obviously I need to lose your
hands are gross thank you oh you can
actually get it to go away if you switch
your weapons that's interesting mm oh I
see so I do appreciate a good mob that
keeps kind of the spirit alive without
kind of tearing down too much of what
was already there yeah not only that
because it's on the source engine they
actually incorporate some physics
puzzles from you know I take take
half-life 2 they're using the engine to
its advantage which I appreciate
they do things with it that you couldn't
do Oh this area I just worked it serious
yeah yeah it's been in development for
over 10 years why it's using ps2
graphics this looks like a ps2
definitely not ps2 graphics 360 though
360 ps3 yeah I could hear an argument
for that it runs on the wallet cuz you
know half-life 2 yeah yeah it is running
on the half-life 200 how many times am I
gonna beat doom eternal at least like
three or four I know it oh I think I
killed him Oh No whoops only because I
don't know if they have that arcade mode
and I the arcade mode is what really
kept me going in 2016 I want to play the
multiplayer you want to play the
multiplayer too we're probably gonna do
a bit of that on community Fridays which
is shall we do every fret there was a
perfect : I'm gonna keep going uh puny
Friday is a show that John Luke and I do
every single Friday at 2:00 p.m. Pacific
this week we playing Halo one on the the
PC because it just came out on Steam and
we want to hang out with you guys and
drive warthogs
and do all sorts of fun silly Halo
things so please if you like that or if
you want to play doom Eternals
multiplayer with us at some point if we
figure out how to get that to work
good follow the channel also please
follow channels so you can continue to
hang out with us because I like all of
you no one's been mean to me yet today
so I hope you all stay and we can all
hang out and play video games together
imagine people playing gym 2016 two
internal when they're really angry
you're stressed it's a really good
comfort game and that if it is a game
like if I've had like a rough day or
like a rough week or something I'll just
go home and kind of like time to start
up doing 2016 again just play the
section the level that just has the BFG
division song so exactly how the white
boards have a lot of lore on them yeah I
really appreciate the attention to
detail they put on like the white boards
and the Environmental Design it really
has that light half-life like just very
detailed texture work periodic table of
elements yeah I always need that it's
important to stores my childhood
yeah that's the same exact thing Jim Jim
was real into Toy Story when I was
growing up and I feel real bad that I
missed three when it happened because it
probably would hit me the same way that
I hit you
John Luke when you were oh yeah I've
seen it originally but uh yet we're
stories a ride I am very excited to see
for though when I can
no one should be mean to you you're
funny and have nice hats and your voice
is pleasant huh what's happening this is
so nice thank you I appreciate it it's
really nice to get good comments we we
try our vests I'm pretty sure there's a
few scientists hiding out somewhere in
the labs maybe with the both of us
looking we can track them down and get
them to let us out of here okay I'm
ready all right let's do it man I can't
believe we've already found Barney
Calhoun there's dr. kleiner there's
another dr. kleiner and there's a
recliner chair it's all coming together
everything's here in this room okay
Chapa
cafeteria first Oh more dr. Kleiner's
who would have done that cocobolo I only
kind cue that's good we would have grape
god I forgot sodas on deck
sodas on the floor toasted roasted I
appreciate that
some ramblers oh god that texture hold
on hold on read it from across then I'm
gonna noscope those we got some naked
fries huh ramblers does this mean that
ramblers is like officially like a brand
in guess so cuz I think that the
sentence is accepted this is a thing
I always love fake fake names to come up
with for stuff ya really hope we meet
kleiner again in half life Alex I hope
we run into a whole bunch of a bunch of
much older people but I like I think
kleiner will show up for sure we are
kind of speculating on because because
they keep saying it runs like oh how
much how familiar you have to be with
half life and you'd think not that much
because it's a prequel but they keep
saying like you should probably reget
caught up on Episode two time travel
that'd be cool time travel like they
spoiler
save Eli time travel
okay if time travel happens now likes
heard it here first
here's my theory is that okay I have two
theories either they're going to
after the end of the prequel they're at
the end of Alex they're gonna kind of
cut back and they're gonna like reshow
the ending of episode 2 to kind of come
back full circle and like remind you
about it or there's a speech that Vance
gives you near the end of to where he
talks about how he knows g-man and how
he made a deal with g-man that kind of
like kept Alex safe yeah and that he
regrets doing it and so there's I
clearly like some past history between
the two of them I think you're gonna see
that that but if that event is not going
to be in Alex or that event is going to
be referenced in in Alex and play a part
of the story what if because g-man's
gonna be in Alex we know he's gonna be
in there what if the control switch is
over to you playing as the g-man and
you get to just go around and beat up
bored of guns with your suit briefcase
thing ya know that I be in for all that
that's my theory
can't wait to meet the g-man of VR it's
gonna be wild I love the look of this
yeah all front entrance here well you
spent so much time like in like the
Underground's it's fun to go back
because you start in a lab and then
you're in the underground and you kind
of end up back in a different lab yeah
cool half-life 2 looks really good on
the Xbox one X when it's enhanced shame
it's only capped at 30fps shoot oh is is
the Orange Box backwards compatible if
that's the only way to play like vanilla
tf2 wow that in a ps3 yeah that's true
yeah that would make sense just play as
the g-man a g-man simulator where you
just pop up in random places and make
people feel awkward oh that's pretty
good yeah it's kind of like your goal is
to like wait for the player character to
be an environment okay okay okay start
walking start walking move move move I
gotta walk walk across his balcony don't
look at him don't look at him keep going
keep going
Josh I adjusted I move nailed it nailed
it
it's like a sneak King but you're the Qi
man in half life that would be really
good yeah I'm into it let's let's get
that that that mob going oh I have Daryl
Dixon Lange came with the crossbow thank
you I normally don't like the crossbow
because it's very demanding precision if
it comes to like snipers or precision
weapons and games I'm not usually that
great that's the revolver I love the
revolver still just feels really good to
shoot it's such an iconic half-life
weapon to the point where macri's
revolver in an overwatch is a homage to
the half-life 1 revolver I didn't even
think about that
totally it like the blizzard is straight
up set it damn that's really great I'm
pretty sure they say it in a series of
videos that we did at GameSpot acts Oh
Hank for
for overwatch that Danny did back in
2016 finally some og streamers oh man
we're here for you hang it out playing
these these old games made new again
having a good time
this just making me want to play half
like this I have so many things I have
to finish I can't do this but I am like
I'm so close to being done with Dragon
Quest I'm right on the edge of it and
once I finished that so much time is
gonna be freed up for so many video
games yeah I don't think I kill them
know what you hit him though we get to
Grandma's back hello Oh welcome back
Richie it's good to see you back again
that sounds good
yeah as I say it's as soon as all those
shots happen I think it's a good look
you didn't see anything
a blue screen is that it this is uh Oh
hit that button yeah right those guys
good bye hi
BuChE I am this is version 1.1 point out
it is however it's the version of 1.0
that was in the public beta yeah when we
started the stream they'd still not
actually release 1.0 which is weird
because it's supposed to be released
today but it is available to grab you
can still technically played this
version and it's just not at least again
at the time of the start of the stream
it had not officially been pushed out
yet but anyone can can just play it in
like their tests their testing you just
have to right click go to properties and
check it out what if in software work on
halflife 3 what if Mick Gordon did the
soundtrack for half-life 3 that'd be
interesting very different games oh yeah
cuz you gotta wonder what that that
mashup would look like no I was already
here it's a cliff valve allow this to be
sold yeah that's my I remember that
boardroom meeting room how I totally
going in circles yeah it is really cool
that Valve let this thing come out okay
there's that yeah yeah this is where I'm
supposed to go here we go this looks
like progress yeah because this is where
you you just zap those dudes mm-hmm what
toxin Hey Oh baby here yep
oh hello he didn't get a chance to do
anything you just kind of stared at you
deer in the headlights that's cuz you
were you're flashing your flashlight
armor that yeah I know I see those
scientists and they're all like we're
gonna do
but as soon as like I walk into a room
where I see like saws strapped to the
ceiling like that come on good right
yeah I'm just like oh haunted as hell
I'm not gonna be here this is it's gonna
go bad eventually OC theta comes in and
talks about Sven co-op we just get a
whole new spend going kind of like
expansive this area's yeah boys oh yeah
she's just like doom guy get him do my
bidding get him get him kill him yeah
all right in the name yeah then you have
to then they've they've had a taste of
blood and they can't stop where you get
a little little Zen this game called
bright memory that's an early access now
wait bright memories being remade that's
like the the Chinese developed like
Devil May Cry shooting game everyone was
the remaking it are they're redoing it
that's just Carly last year wasn't thank
you I think it's still early access Oh
glory kills with a grav gun that'd be
real real great you guys at GameSpot
starting to excited for next-gen I know
I am oh demo info on oh oh yeah we're
constantly thinking about it
I can't wait for like we don't really
know what's happening like the second
half of this year when you think about
it so like come around
III time Post III time is very unknown
as the XIII itself so yeah that's that's
nothing that's being called undoing
but around that time we should have like
more info on what's gonna be coming
what games to expect it's like I'm
excited about the hardware obviously cuz
it's its new hardware but I want to see
what what we're gonna be getting like
what games am I going to be playing on
this outside of someone like the old
stuff but I'm very excited we're all
very excited and we can't wait to figure
out more info this way
well that system shock remake is really
cool they said they they had like
there's a demo they put out on Steam for
like Gamescom or something you could
download or packs what the yeah so I got
to play it a bit so they did a demo way
back in 2016 I remember this because it
was one of the first videos I ever made
for GameSpot lose a video comparing it
to the original system shock and then
they did some progress and then they
said hey we're putting the whole thing
on hiatus for a little bit so we kind of
need to reevaluate it but they recently
like I've been giving more updates and
progress on it so it's still happening
it's actually making good progress I'm
very excited about it okay apparently
the bright memory it's called bright
memory infinite and there they're
redoing it that's good I'm excited for
more that it was really fun when I when
I played it
yeah that rocket was felt like it was
right there liquid is speaking my
language you want to talk about Power
Stone give give me all power stone you
can I only hold on to my Vita Vita means
life so I can play the Power Stone one
and two collection and I just probably
finished persona 4 golden at some point
but that's besides the fact the power
stone is on it and I played all the time
I did kill for a Power Stone something
all right some hot laser puzzles you
remember this yeah whoa dang uh surprise
got kleiner say you doing laser things
again oh my gosh they were talking about
the charge and it was it was all there
Oh chirping I've been here a lot about
your pain too
the other one that I've been playing
recently and want more content for is
get to the orange door if you like those
kind of like action II first-person
shooters you should definitely check
that one out there's not much there yet
there's a workshop on steam that let you
download stuff but oh no oh no the boots
oh baby that's just the door opening in
Doom that is you can't pull a fast one
on me I know that sound anywhere then
the music kicks in you're like oh yeah
new gun new music let's go
[Music]
yeah anytime there's a new trailer for
doom eternal I get real stove she's here
more that Mick Gordon music you know if
you guys haven't yet you want to hear
more really good Mick Gordon jams
you should play killer instinct she did
like for two-thirds of the soundtrack
for that game it's also a very good
fighting game
you'll have to check out that bright
memory trailer that's it's out so I
didn't even know that they're doing
appreciate the heads-up about it that
was very unnecessary
I was actually a waste of a mile but it
was fun
hey it looked cool and that's what
matters excited for our three week above
all else
oh yeah III make there are so many
things I'm so excited for that I forgot
a remake of one of my favorite
PlayStation games of all time this is
where we are this year I'm really
excited that after we had we had remake
yeah capital R capital re make but then
we just had like o remake too and it's
like yeah but now we have three make
yeah three make is is the jam yeah
cinder steam is really good
still of was orchids theme I like oh boy
oh man look at all those guys oh no his
Socko sockos dad I was might be one of
my favorite most recent fighting game
characters you know play a lot of games
me recognize several sound effects like
the woman or the doom door opening that
that doom door opening sound is
ingrained in the back of my head because
I played like doom and hexon when I was
definitely way too young to play it and
the dorsum especially because every new
room I went into the hall all their new
possibility of being like super scared
of what was going on I really appreciate
that a lot of the sound effects in
half-life are still in Alex yeah like
and their sound effects that have been
in since like the original half-life
like there's just a iconic sound effects
II associate with a game
silence some sound design is such a big
thing in people with people often don't
think about it
between three best suit best in the
series really able to remake earth here
game of 2019 it's a very good game
beaver game it was one of mine it was I
think it I think it end up being my
number one I was one of the wacky people
that picked death stranding for their
favorite game from last year and then I
was also one of those weird people who
had a judgment at the top of their lists
when I came time to even like talk about
Game of the Year I was like I mentioned
judgment because their judgment was he
was in my top but it was pretty low so
then I didn't even bother talking about
I saw Miam files all it's a fantastic
visual novel game if you can stomach
visual novels I still need one more one
more beam spinals is great cuz like
anytime you get your combo up then all
of a sudden like the chant comes in it's
just uh well a lot of friends who are
really into Thunder steam to people who
I know picked Thunder just because of
his theme the redone version of the Halo
like the halo theme music from that one
was really good but I don't you don't
think that was Mick though I think that
was those like posts him leaving and the
like a guy from Celldweller taking over
it was someone else
music still very good but it's it's not
macgowran what happened it ghost wire a
we actually you guys played it at PAX
right that ghost runner ghost runner not
different game wire too many ghost
Southwire is the that's the that's the
game does the one world you disappeared
and it's got a sweater to him and who me
Nakamura except not if she's not there
anymore
she works at Sony 10 locking out
like yeah that's a good question where's
ghost lawyer it's good laser tests I
like it fired again you to get back into
monster honor I've been thinking about
it I need there's just no time visual
novels
you guys are immense of culture I see oh
hell yeah it would you know it you're
you're in the middle of a visual novel
playthrough Phoenix right right now part
of my sign-off is telling people to play
thong and roppa which are both kind of
like they're out there visual novels but
now there's actually a visual novel sale
on Steam happening right now if you want
to check out some of those the first
danganronpa game is literally eight
dollars you should play it
it's got great music Jake's is loading
as I'm falling and taking damage it's
perfect couldn't planned it any better
all right what's the visual novel game
again oh the one I was talking about I
guess it's called AI somnium files
that's very good all these Kleiner's we
all have retinal scanner access there
dr. kleiner voice is pretty good yeah
yes but you'll have to shut down the
surgical unit first the state of this
device is in decline
I get it because my name is kleiner
so I just have to like I'll rat roll
your body at it okay let's see if I were
Gordon Freeman percussive maintenance I
just shoot all of it other guy they were
like he didn't make it show he was close
though look out dude he's so fast and
what is going on with Dead Island 2
because that we thought that it wasn't
the thing and then they came back and
they're like it's still something like
that but yeah outside of that the kind
of cool trailer I don't think we've seen
much maybe it's quiet too quiet
[Music]
cheer that hear that sound okay that
helicopter oh yeah they're here
crank it up I'll give you a little bit
yeah this is a banger
[Music]
it's all good
every kill
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you let it die down for a sec with metal
yeah my favorite thing is I don't in my
head this is just like Gordon Freeman
imagining this music well yeah yeah he's
gotta take these dudes out let's go yeah
he's just imagining it all on his head
there he's got some like a Walkman on oh
there it is
Jean Luc Freeman if you somehow survived
long enough to make it across the base
you'll find the labs where the rest of
the science team has taken shelter I
couldn't dare risk venturing out there
but I can inform those of us who remain
in the lambda complex that you are
coming I'll have my people call your
people looking at the one but then the
voice coming from behind yeah the last
of us part two and ghosts coming up I'm
excited for both of those it's good
stuff
all right well it's just use
Oh God
that guy I'm gonna reload no thanks this
dream long live doctor recliner and
kleiner and long live free Minh hey
thanks for hanging out and I'm glad that
you had a good time and I hope you have
a good rest of your day these these
chairs and doctors online that shotguns
a little a little intense I'm gonna
bring it down a bit that's gay I don't
want to like mess with your flow too
much I just punched my micro I'm so
sorry
these guys are definitely eating these
bullets sandwiches ain't even ain't even
flinching not having a rough time at all
which one of these cars do you think is
Gordon I was about to say uh this one I
hope it's that one that's cool and as
soon as I saw it I knew I had to ask
oh my god my car oh no not again
Louisville half-life games they're good
games to love very good games oh you
ain't so that's that's another one two
cyberpunk I don't think about it because
it's not like it feels so far away it
feels far away and I feel like I know
it's gonna be a game that I'm gonna love
once I play it so I'm not even like I'm
not worried when the next thing for it's
coming I'm more like just give me the
game totally where's like Animal
Crossing I'm like I need to know all the
information tell me I'll tell me the
villagers show me the new froggy chairs
like doom let me see the weapons let me
hear that new make Gordon's like track
hit me with it
cyberpunk I'm just like I accept it for
whatever it is just let me play yeah I
think once once everything else has come
out I'll have more time to really think
about cyberpunk I wound up quitting it
for a few hours because the soldier
super bullets Bungie well-made game
though yeah that's that's fair it's not
for everyone but can't can't get upset
anyone see you tried it you know as long
as you try it that's all you can ask for
[Music]
not cool
nailed it
that guy just flew like 20 feet that
having physics are really fun yeah yeah
everything explode
just this morning Gordon Freeman was
only a scientist now he's a murderer
[Music]
I'm not a mother
never made sense me at the mp5 is a
grenade launcher all our weapons are
better yeah that's fair
oh yeah yeah yeah Kevlar has the
alternate weapon skins that I think came
with either blue shifter opposing forces
Africa which one gonna fool me when
cyberpunk comes out I feel that I really
feel that not even like like I'm not
even gonna look up like character stuff
or what I'm gonna build
initially I'm just gonna like I'm just
gonna throw myself at it and just have a
good time
me too I wanna go in as blind as
possible keep forgetting Freeman as a
scientist Yeah right cuz whenever you
really see him it's just him just smoke
when she's shooting but yeah he's he's
the science a man's side he's got a
theoretical physics degree man that's
true
MIT graduate guy knows his stuff he also
knows his smg's grenade launchers and
pistols though he also knows jumping on
top of trucks those are the theoretical
physics that he likes
Oh
the the momentary pauses that whole
course they landed at your feet exactly
what you needed ooh
half-life ouch or Final Fantasy 7 remake
so I I'm planning on playing Final
Fantasy 7 in the original for the first
time as soon as I finish up my Dragon
Quest playthrough so I'm very very
excited for Final Fantasy 7 remake and I
was kind of just like y'all play it
whatever just to kind of like get my
thing going but after I played the demo
remake shot up to be one of my most
anticipated games this year
demo is really good you can get serious
yes I say oh [ __ ] what that skybox is
really nice though oh there it is oh
we're good now you picked up a bullying
law
well this is a finished game way back
then what's changed only the Zen map so
what what are the things that are
included so the sense Benton for a
little bit 1.0 Sun came in like n2 last
year 1.0 is added they've completely
redone a lot of the like menu UI stuff
they have cleaned up the AI on the enemy
soldiers they've redone some of the
texture work for the older areas for
example like these rock faces are a lot
better now to kind of like make it more
in line with with with Zen so I think
it's just to give it a more cohesive
feel and to them that's like yep that's
one point out now they've also said they
plan on continuing to support and update
it even past one point out but it is now
at a point where they're like yes is
this a finished
this is game product wow wow talak
presents probably my favourite bit of
now in my head Canon gordon freeman kind
of character building they said
Freeman's probably guy who bought a Zune
dude I bought it soon as I mean I feel
like gordon freeman is the type of guy
who would have bought a Zune and that's
that's in my head now as a cannon thing
night like I'm into it
it's Sunter pretty good I had a friend
who had one I had the iPod iPod like the
first video one yeah what you guys take
a serious Sam I love it
I love the sound that Sam makes when he
jumps I love back peddling and shooting
multiple monsters something the damn
fight is completely different yeah I
don't remember it being like this I
assume they changed it a while ago
when I mentioned man who yea critical
said that Final Fantasy 7 is a religion
a lot of people saying they're more
excited for the Final Fantasy 7 remake
over half-life Alex which is
understandable and I'm honestly very
excited to finally figure out what's up
with Final Fantasy 7 like to actually
give it a go and like understand why
everyone loves it as much as I do my
thing is I never played Final Fantasy 7
growing up so I'm excited to play it and
like experience it alex is a more
immediate excitement because I grew up
playing half-life
I am excited I'm excited for all of it
can't believe it we get some more mind
Freeman episodes that's a heck of a call
Freeman's mind he's still doing those
yeah you know the one that I got caught
up in it was a little bit after that was
gorgeous Freeman how off like a familiar
that one
it's a weird like a round man like the
first episode was done in Garry's Mod
and then they moved over to source
filmmaker when that came out so it's
kind of round that time I just like how
dumb it is it's it's just a retelling of
the half-life 2 story but stupid and me
me and it's perfect okay veneering it
could be Knights of the Old Republic
someone's got your number John Luke yeah
bring it up kotor that's one of my
favorite games of all time there you go
dan this is stuff and i'm on a damn the
hardest damn level in the game
well good there are other people out
there who know gorgeous Freeman that's
good I know a lot of people don't like
it I should probably go back and watch
it cuz it's been a while but uh yes I
feel about most
I remember giggling when I was younger
watching it I'm always like worried like
most stuff I watched and being like yeah
there's a lot of okay I'm just gonna
make the run right into the water can
you do that can you step in the water I
forget mmm oh you could try not let's
just do it yeah there we go there
perfect
The Lost Planet be great for something
good
oh god I forgot about these guys I'd
like a new Lost Planet with that that
new Monster Hunter tech I actually
really like Lost Planet especially -
that was a mistake go back to the shed
see if I can get more Oh perfect let's
try now
yeah I think you beat the helicopter
he's gotta jump in the water that's yeah
I feel like that's what it was - I'm
just
still so accurate shooting through that
water like that well the guys that fish
is drifting yeah it's gonna say not not
many people out there who would admit to
enjoying Lost Planet 2 but I played
hundreds of hours of it's it's it's just
space monster honor with going to hell
into the hangar bring it back sure lost
plant two to three your mates the other
day so holds up well heck yeah
such a good time there's so many
unlockables
you could play as Frank West in it like
oh and all three lost plants are
apparently back compatible on Xbox one
so you can have a good time not playing
three and play the other two three had
some interesting things but I am NOT the
biggest fan of it I'll play one into any
day though
mm-hmm-hmm let's plays he was the only
one who played loved it at the time to
revisit it at some point love the max
monsters and the train the train level
is the one that's like permanently
engrained into my head because it was
just lost planet at that point had
always been like it's gotta be snowy and
cold thermal energy is important but
you're like what if we had a giant boss
fight in the desert with the Train it
was good
oh yeah and Marcus and Dom were playable
I think you'd be Wesker - not cool
things with that just finished ice born
while we're on the topic heck yeah that
last fight and ice born is a heck of a
thing still kind of get uncomfortable
when I see that monster but you know
it's all good times like unsorted
machine gun three I think I used a gun
sword more because I thought it was
cooler I don't have any like numbers to
back it up
but I also loved just jumping and
shotgunning people all the time like
most most of my like in my head
[Music]
memories of like actually shooting
things in Lost Planet was me jumping
towards something and then landing and
then shooting immediately after hitting
the ground with a shotgun point-blank I
might not have been like the best lost
planet player but I actually I should
have played a lot of the multiplayer in
the first one a pretty good time with
that not being able to read the text nor
that explicitly
look
get that Lost Planet 2 remake going
again oh boy what if we brought that for
community Fridays we lost planet too
hey man I'm down oh yeah oh we are it's
3:30 I think that means we're at the
time you are at time and I do have a
couple other things I didn't take care
of today before yeah but what if we just
played half-life and hung out with
everyone else it sounds really nice -
I'm into that idea
we just hold everyone everyone would
understand right absolutely like sorry
there were headcrabs to get and we had
to talk about Lost Planet 2 more I'm
very guilty of choosing aesthetic over
practicality in games I used to be able
to like rationalize it to be like I'll
pick the worst weapon that I know looks
cooler because it means that I'll have
to spend more time like fighting
whatever I'm fighting like I'll take the
underpowered gun that I like
aesthetically so that it will take more
shots to kill the enemies that I'm
playing and therefore I'm playing more
game like it was a dumb idea that I had
but yeah I'm all about that Resident
Evil Rising revengeance I play it I play
I play so much of it yeah Wesker a
Wesker beat him up a Wesker character
action game if you play Lost Planet 2
warned me but I'm gonna get running on
PC once you do it's all good I might
mess around with it a bit but if you
guys do want to keep up state with what
we plan community Friday's it's this is
the best way to do is just see what's
going on on the channel but well I'm not
sure to go which i think is probably a
good just yeah stop for now for sure
anyway yeah there's been Black Mesa I
had a really fun time playing it it's a
heck of a good game I'm gonna switch the
camera over really quick as soon as I
remember where everything is Oh where's
the camera there you go
that's
not it that's true and try one yeah yeah
we could be rich eating also rich yeah
yeah perfect just like we planned it
he's Richie I'm also Richie you've been
watching Richie and also Richie play
half-life thanks for watching with those
guys we really appreciate it
thanks for hanging out and again if you
did enjoy this I encourage you to
definitely subscribe to the channel we
do streams every weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific our show that we usually do is
on Fridays we'll play games with you
guys tomorrow come back for that
we're playing Halo on the PC and you
know you want to be there because halo
is just a good time we'll probably end
up side railing it and talking about
Lost Planet 2 again or whatever else
we've been doing this this whole time
it'll be good though and you should be
there yeah you got anything else you
wanna say no that's about it alright
guys well goodbye everybody good where
the buttons otro close it out